hey guys
welcome to simply learn's youtube
channel today we will be learning
cable u for data science so we will get
started with a brief introduction to w
followed by that we will understand the
fundamentals of w where we will be
covering the overall tools and
functionalities available in table
u later we will dive into the practical
part where we will have hands-on session
and try to design and develop
real-time data sense projects and
dashboards i hope i made myself clear
with the agenda
before we get started make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel if you
haven't already
don't forget to hit that bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
so what is w so before we understand
what exactly is w
let us imagine a simple situation
imagine that you're
an office worker and you get some loads
of data
maybe like millions of rows or billions
of rows and you are supposed to extract
the
insights of that particular data so what
do you do you basically load that data
into a database
and try to write the sql commands and
then try to extract the
insights of that particular data so this
kind of approach is basically time
consuming and you get exhausted
now what if you had a tool
which could write all the sql commands
for you in the background
and all you had to do is just to drag
and drop the data
sounds interesting right so tableau is
just the same
all you have to do is just drag and drop
the data and it will automatically write
all the sql commands you ever wanted to
write on that particular data
and it will give you live data
interactions
and advices for the future now with this
let us understand the definition of
w so basically tableau is a business an
analytical software tool developed in
america
w helps people to understand visualize
and make
data driven decisions in real time with
extreme
agility and accuracy now with this
let us continue with the next topic
which will be about the various versions
of w
so at first we have the tableau desktop
so tableau desktop is a data
visualization application to facilitate
you
to examine virtually any kind of
structured data
and generate highly interactive
beautiful graphs
dashboards and reports within minutes
once a quick installation
you can tie to virtually any data source
from spreadsheets to
data warehouses and display information
in several graphic perspectives
designed to be easy to utilize you'll be
working more rapidly than ever before
next we have the w server it is a
business intelligence
application that offers browser-based
analytics anyone can utilize
it is a rapid-fire alternative to the
slow pace of traditional business
intelligence software
it is an online solution meant for
sharing distributing and
collaborating on content created in w
what makes w different it is proposed to
everyone
there is no scripting required so
everyone can grow to be an analytics
expert
you can grow your deployment as you
require it
train online for free finances in
minutes and not in months
that's the speciality of w now followed
by the w server
we have w online
so w online is a business intelligence
application that
offers browser-based analytics anyone
can utilize
as discussed before it is a rapid fire
alternative to slow-paced traditional
business intelligence software
so tableau online is a secure
cloud-based solution for sharing and
collaborating on tableau views
and dashboards next up we have the w
public
so now i want to give you guys a serious
heads up if you're a beginner in w w
public is like an open source whatever
the data you choose to work on
using tableau public it goes to public
so kind of like
wpublic is not preferable if you want to
work on your company's sensitive and
confidential data
w public is a free software to
facilitate anyone to get connected to a
spreadsheet
or a file and create interactive data
visualizations
for the web it is delivered as a service
that permits the user
to be up to and running overnight with
tableau public
users can construct amazing interactive
visuals and publish them quickly
without the help of programmers or id it
is designed for organizations to
facilitate their websites
with interactive data visualizations
there are higher limits on the size of
data you can work with
and among other features you can keep
your underlying data hidden
and lastly we have w reader
w reader is a free desktop application
that you can use to open
and interact with data visualizations
built in tableau desktop
with tableau reader you can filter drill
down and discover humongous loads of
data
now moving ahead we have the features of
w
so these are the few important features
that you might want to consider
those are the first one robust security
tableau takes special care of data and
user security
it has a foolproof security-based
authentication
and permission systems for data
connections and users access
w also gives you the freedom to
integrate with other security protocols
such as
active directory kerberos etc an
important point to note here is that the
tableau practices
low level filtering which helps in
keeping the data secure
followed by that we have the
collaboration and sharing feature
tableau provides convenient options to
collaborate with other users and
instantly share data in the form of
visualizations sheets
dashboards etc in real time it allows
you to securely share data from various
data sources
such as on-premise on cloud hybrid etc
instant and easy collaboration and data
sharing helps in
getting quick reviews or feedback on
data leading
to a better overall analysis of it
another extremely useful feature of w
is the use of time series and
forecasting easy creation of trendlines
and forecasting is possible due to
tableau's powerful backend
and dynamic front-end you can easily get
data predictions such as
a forecast or a trendline by simply
selecting some options and drag and drop
operations
using your concern fields next up we
have
live and in memory data tableau ensures
connectivity with both
live data sources and data extraction
from external sources as
in memory data this gives the user the
flexibility to use the data from
more than one type of data source
without any restrictions
you can use data directly from data
source by establishing live data
connections
or keep that data in memory by
extracting data from a data source
as per their requirement tableau
provides additional features to support
data connectivity such as an automatic
extract refreshes
notifying the user upon live connection
fail etc
next we have informative view and even
the mobile view
one of the key features of w and the one
that got its popularity is its wide
range of visualizations
in w you can make visualizations such as
bar chart
pie chart gantt chart bullet chart
motion chart
tree map box plot and many more
like you name it w got it you can select
and create any kind of visualizations
easily by selecting the visualization
type from the show me tab
apart from that it is capable to
represent data
in mobile view as well tableau
acknowledges the importance of mobile
phones in today's world and provides the
mobile versions of tableau
app the next and the last feature is
that being capable of accessing data
from various kinds of data sources
tableau offers a wide range of data
source options where you can get
connected and fetch data from data
sources ranging from
on-premise files spreadsheets relational
databases
non-relational databases online cloud
data
to data warehouses and many more so
followed by the features now we will
discuss about the advantages of w
so following are the advantages of using
w first one
it has remarkable visualization
capabilities
of course the unparalleled capabilities
of visualizing information is on top of
the list
of tableau's software benefits followed
by that we have the ease of use
the tool's intuitive manner of creating
graphics and a user-friendly interface
allows non-developers to utilize the
basic apps functionalities
to the fullest users arrange raw data
into
catchy diagrams in a drag-and-drop way
which facilitates
information analyzing and eliminates the
need for the help of it department and
patent building
next high performance apart from its
high visualization functionality
uses rates its overall performance as
robust and reliable
the tool also operates fast on big data
which makes it powerful performance on
an important point
on the list of the advantages of w and
next
is the mobile friendliness one of our
best advantages out of the tableau
benefits is its efficient mobile
application which is available for both
ios and android
it adds mobility to tabular users and
allows them to keep statistics at their
fingertips as well as supports their
functionality
that desktop and online versions have
and finally
we have the thriving community and forum
w has a rich community
the number of w fans who invest their
expertise and skills in the community is
increasing rapidly
business users can beef up their
knowledge on data passing and reporting
and get many useful insights in this
community
also forum visitors are ready to help
settle any user issues and
also share their experience next up we
have the disadvantages of w
the first major disadvantage is the high
cost
the tableau is not the most expensive
visualization
software especially compared to such
business intelligent giant such as
oracles and ibm solutions all the same
the license is quite costly for small
and medium companies which makes it one
of the considerable tables disadvantages
next is the inflexible pricing tableau
sales team is not flexible enough to
provide
case-by-case approach for their
customers ignoring the fact that each
company has its own
unique requirements for visualization
tool package the tableau sales model
requires clients to purchase an extends
license
from the start as a result
a lot of companies that use w arrive at
the conclusion that
they don't need all their license
features they would prefer to buying a
set of requirements and scale them if
necessary
followed by that the next disadvantage
is poor after sales support
on multiple message boards users
complain that tableau software lacks
proper after sales maintenance
if customer has software performance
problem the support team does not settle
the matter by investigating the problems
root and eliminating it
next we have the power bi capability or
the poor business intelligence
capability
as previously mentioned the tool
provides best-in-class information
visual interpretation however
it lacks the functionality required for
a fully fleshed business intelligence
tool such as
large-scale reporting the building of
data tables and statistical layouts
and lastly the poor versioning only the
reason tableau versions support revision
history
while for the older ones software
rolling back is impossible
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more
so tableau is a business and analytical
software tool developed in america
w helps people to understand visualize
and make data driven decisions in real
time
with extreme agility and accuracy
to better understand what exactly
tableau does let us imagine that you're
given some data in the form of excel
sheet
that has thousands or even lacks of rows
and some hundreds of columns or even
thousands of columns
and you had to kind of filter or kind of
apply some operations on that and get
some insights of that particular data
so basically if you do it in a brute
force method it could be really time
consuming
but what if there is a software that can
write all the sql queries possible on
your data and
all the data you wanted is readily
available or all the information you
ever wanted on your data is readily
available
just by a single click yes exactly
that's what exactly tableau does it
automatically writes all your sql
queries in the background
and it can provide you the information
in the form of a variety of charts
like the bar charts pie charts and it
can even give you some live data
and also the advices based on which you
can
move ahead and improve your business now
let's go through some sample data and
understand how it
exactly does it
so on my screen you can see some excel
data which is based on
some store in america so here you will
be having different regions
of america that is south north east
and west and the category of furnitures
subcategory bookcase and etc etc
which kind of category is selling most
in which kind of region
and what's the discount what's the
quantity and what's the profit etc etc
in this particular excel data
so you'll be using this particular excel
data to
get some insights of this sales
happening in america
so this is how business intelligence
works basically
so here we should use the microsoft
excel to get the necessary insights of
this particular data
now just select all these cells of this
particular excel
and select insert and on the left corner
you can see pivot table
select that and here if you had an
existing worksheet you can select the
existing worksheet
or if you don't have that you can select
the new worksheet option
and then just press ok now we have our
pivot table over here
and we have our fields in the excel data
on the right side part
now just select a region and push that
into the columns
and now let's select sales and push that
into the values
now we have the sum of sales options so
we have the east zone
central zone south zone west zone and
the summation of sales happening in that
particular section
of america or region of america now we
can also make some changes to the values
like we have summation
and we can select some value field
settings and inside that you can go
through count average maximum minimum
and select
few more options based on which you have
to calculate it
now let's push the rows or let's push
the regions from columns to row so that
we can have some good
data in a more understandable form of
view
so there you go you have the central
region east
south and west on the left side and on
the right side you have the
summation of sales happening in that
particular region and the grand total of
the sales
now let's try to do this in the table
so there you go your table you just got
started
so on the left side you have got the
connect option and the various types of
files it supports that is the microsoft
excel
text file json file microsoft access
and more on that in the next upcoming
part where we'll have a tour on that
now let's select excel
so we have already an excel file on the
downloads path
just select that one and just open it
and there you go you can see all the
rows and columns here
now let's go to our sheet
so on the screen you can see that on the
left part we have the data which is
connected to the w that is
sheet one the store data and these are
the dimensions
and these are the measures so basically
tableau divides the
data into dimensions and measures
automatically
and you can see some options provided on
the top row which is the file data
worksheet dashboard story analysis map
format window help etc
and here you can see some marks which is
the color
so he here you can just imagine that you
worked on some
bar data or bar chart so that
you can use color options to provide
different colors to your bus
and you can also select the size of your
bars add some text if you wanted to add
an and you can some add some details if
you wanted
and some tool tips etc and on the right
side you can see
show me option and this particular tray
helps you to get
different types of charts you wanted to
keep on your data
for example you want to select pie chart
you can just select pie chart
if you wanted to go with bar chart you
can go and bar and
some area charts and you can see maps
etc
and the best part is when you hover over
this particular chart or
any kind of selection you wanted to make
then table tableau automatically helps
you
for having the dimensions and measures
for that particular chart
you can see in the bottom part where it
is highlighted for pie charts
try one or more dimensions and one or
two measures
so if you hover over the bar chart you
can see that w tells you for side by
side bar charts
try one or more dimensions and one or
more measures so basically it is telling
you to have one or more dimensions or
one or more measures
in order to use the side by side bar
charts
now let's do the same thing what we did
in excel
so here we'll just select the region
and pull that over the columns and now
we shall select these sales and push
that over the
rows and there you go you can see the
bar chart over here and
it's automatically telling you the kind
of sales happening in
that particular region now you can even
select the region part and drag that
over to color so that it gives you
different colors
now if you see on the right side a show
me tab you can see different types of
charts available for your data so you
can have
a pie chart you can have the bar chart
you can have few more map chats etc etc
so that's how tableau gives you
automatically
all the types of options that you can
work on the
data visualization by using different
types of charts
so that's how tableau basically works
now we will go into the next step where
i'll help you to install tableau into
your local system
once the installation is done we will
get back to w again and we will
understand
each and every part of w in much more
detail and we'll also work on each and
every type of chart present over here
and we'll work on multiple sheets and
finally we'll enter into the dashboard
so far so good i hope you have
understood the basic introduction to
tableau and basics of
the w fundamentals how to use rows and
columns what are dimensions what are
measures
and what does show me and how do you
change colors of your
bar charts over here and you can
highlight this
so we'll work on everything after we
finish the installation process and get
back to worksheets
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
so before we go any further on tableau
installation let us understand
the tableau products first so there are
multiple types of w products
so here we will be having table use
desktop
w public w server
w online and the tableau reader so let
us understand tableau desktop
first tableau desktop is a paid desktop
application
it is also called sw desktop
professional edition this is where the
developers create
charts formula dashboards actions and
everything
it has a 14-day trial too the dashboards
we create here
can be published on any server listed
above
the data can also be opened from tableau
reader moving ahead we shall understand
the tabular desktop
so for beginners let me tell you w
desktop is like
open source data whatever the data or
whatever the sheets whatever the
dashboards you work on
using tableau public will be available
for public
so keep this as your reminder and it is
not preferable if you want to use w for
your company's confidential data
because it might go public and it might
be risky
so tableau public desktop is a free
desktop application
it is the developer place for tableau
public server it is free and has to come
with some limitations like cloud save
only no
live or database connection there are
widely used by learners bloggers
and public information related
institutes like media etc
now moving ahead we have the tableau
server
so w server is a free server in the
internet this is the youtube or blogspot
in tableau data visualization world
it is free and people post their ideas
and visualizations here
we call it the visual blog it has no
user management or
folder management options you can hide
your work though
it cannot have live data source but only
extract
so many people publish their ideas and
custom visualizations here
we could find the inspiration from here
now next we have the tableau online
w online is a paid server application
too
but it is already hosted by tableau
software
and so no need to install it on any
windows server
it is better you need the tableau
dashboards to be accessed from anywhere
it has almost all the features of
tableau server but only on the internet
not on your local system and finally we
have the w
reader so w reader is a free desktop
application which can help us to view
the tableau dashboards
created by tableau desktop it supports
only extract connection files
it can help new people to try tableau by
getting
one license for tablet desktop and
installing this free software
on their end user's machine it can open
the dashboards interact with them like
filtering tooltip and parameters we
cannot edit the formula or charts here
now i hope we have some good
understanding of w
its introduction and the various
products of tableau available for users
now let's begin with installation
so the third segment tableau
installation into your local system
now here we'll be trying the windows
operating system
now to install avenue into your local
system all you have to do is
open google and type in
download tableau public and you have the
first option that reads download now w
public i would recommend for beginners
to select
w public because it is free
now let's go back to google once
now on my screen we have open google
just now type in
download w
so once you type in download w you can
see various options
the first one though is tableau desktop
which is a paid version
as i said you you have to select tableau
and it is free of cost and you can try
out your
sample data over here for free
and once you select the tableau public
option
you have this particular web page open
and
if you go back to the presentation you
can see that i have written something
called abc
gmail.com this is basically your email
address for getting registered and
downloading the application
so you can write in your email over here
which can be anything like i have
written abc
there gmail.com just make sure that the
mail id you provide is an official one
or it is an operational one as you might
have to confirm your download
once you write in your mail id just
select the download app
option and you can see on the bottom
left corner
the application will be getting
downloaded
now i have already downloaded the w
public desktop exe file into my local
system
so i'll just cancel it for now now we
are back on the presentation mode
and we were in this particular stage
where the tabularpublicdesktop.exe
was getting downloaded once the file is
downloaded
just run the file from your downloads
part and you can see this particular
screen on your
windows which will greet you welcome to
w
and here you might have to select i have
read and accept all the terms of the
license
and just install and there you go the
w public 2020.4 is installing into your
local system
and that's how you install tableau into
your local system
now we have entered into our next
segment where we will be having the
table you tour
so once you open your tableau your
screen will be looking something like
this
so this is the tableau in my local
system and you'll be having the screen
which is similar to the presentation one
and here you have various options to
connect to your data file
which might be an excel text file json
file microsoft
access pdf file spatial file statistical
file
or if you had to download some data
directly from the server
you can even do that so now we'll be
working with the local data
or the local excel file in your local
system just select that
excel file and open it
and there you go you're on your first
worksheet
just select the go to worksheet option
and you'll be having
your screen redirected directly into the
worksheet
and you have the dimensions and
measurements on your left corner and you
have the show me tab on your right
corner
and some marks in here and filters pages
and various options on your toolbar
now we have finished the introductory
tour to our tableau
and we'll understand more about all the
options provided in this particular
w screen through our worksheets as we
start with our first
worksheet so far we have understood what
is business intelligence and the
tabula's role in improving your business
followed by that we have understood what
exactly w is
then we have understood how to install
tableau into your local system
and we had a brief introduction our
brief tour on w
now we will move ahead and continue with
making our own
worksheets and the dashboards based on
the worksheets we have worked with
so advancing into the fifth part we will
be working with the worksheets
and followed by the worksheets we will
be working on the sixth
part which is the dashboards now without
further ado
let's get back to w so we have
successfully booted up
our w and we are on the home screen of
the w
and on the left bar we can see that we
have various connect options
to the microsoft excel text file json
file
microsoft access pdf file spatial file
statistical file etc and
if you had to connect to a server this
particular option is not provided in the
public
w it might be available in the server w
and you can see that if you had to
connect to the server in just in case
then you're provided with various
options here like you can connect with
google sheets
or data web data connector etc etc
so today we'll be working with local
data that is present in my local system
that happens to be an excel file
so you can see that in my downloads we
have a set of excel files
so we'll be selecting car sales updated
data file
now you can see that the data has been
connected to the tab view and
the rows and columns have been presented
on the screen so
before getting started with tableau
let's have a quick
update on the data
so many times it happens that you
download a data from
google and sometimes one of the other
rows or columns
might have some incomplete data as you
can see there is an incomplete
cell over here which is a curve weight
of a particular vehicle
that happens to be cadillac's valley you
can either try to remove this row or you
can add some value over here
like i'm going to add some value i'm
just going to drag this one
because they both look a little bit
similar they have a same wheelbase
and the kind of scene but so might be
the curb weight
might match so we'll just drag it over
here or we'll just
write it okay i forgot to enable editing
fine so i'll just drag it here and i
will have some values
let's change it a little bit
okay so you can see that we have filled
up the
cell over here let's just check if
anything else is incomplete
yeah there is another one incomplete
over here
let us just add some random values
because this is just for practice
here everything else seemed to be fine
so the important point or the update i
wanted to give you
guys is that when you save this so when
you get into a file and save as
sales updated so when you save it
make sure that you select the excel
workbook
if you don't select the excel workbook
you might face some troubles
while connecting the data to your table
here that was the important update i
wanted to give you guys
so just select okay and your data has
been saved now
and let's get back to w now let's
connect the data again
by selecting the connect data option you
can see the
dialog box come up on my screen so you
can just select microsoft excel and
car sales updated open and
you can see the data got connected just
now again
and you can see the rows and columns
over here so everything looks fine
and now let's get back to our sheet
so this is the sheet we'll be working on
we'll be creating multiple sheets
so we're creating multiple sheets
because we have some options over here
you can see that right
so this is the sheet and this is the new
sheet option
and this is the new dashboard option and
this is
a storyteller option so basically we'll
be working on multiple
sheets and then we'll start a new
dashboard and we will drag
all the sheets that we have worked on
onto the dashboard so that
we can have a view on all the sheets in
one single screen
so basically that's what dashboard is
there are multiple operations on
dashboard like connecting to multiple
dashboards together and
applying some operations like filter etc
on the dashboards
we will learn more advanced topics on
dashboards in the advanced part
which is the next part two of the w
tutorial
so we'll have a basic understanding of w
functions in this particular part one
right now
no worries on that so you can see that
we have
uh options or the row names
written in two different colors you can
see that the manufacturer
model vehicle type etc are written in
blue
and we can see that there is some sort
of abc text
represented on the left side and
similarly on the
other half you can see the curve weight
engine size fuel capacity
fuel efficiency horsepower length price
etc
and you can see that there is an
asterisk written just besides them
so why is this difference because w
automatically categorizes your data so
it will categorize
the data into two forms that is the
dimensions
and measures so the dimensions happen to
be
the unique values of the data and uh
the values are the numerical values used
in your data so
basically the curve weight is a
numerical value
engine size is a numerical value the
price
resale values width wheelbase car sales
etc
are the numerical values and in the
dimensions you have a manufacturer
model vehicle type this happens to be
the non-numerical values so the
manufacturer might be
audi bmw etc etc and the model would be
some 320i from bmw s-class from mercedes
etc etc and vehicle type might be some
just a car or off-roading vehicle
something like that
so these are the non-numerical values so
these are categorized into
uh dimensions so sometimes there
is a chance that you will also find the
numerical values and measures
like just imagine that you are in a
college and
the name address and
your percentage etc etc are your values
and the percentage will be categorized
into
the numbers which is the measures and if
you have a student id which happens to
be a number
that will not be in the measures that
will be in the dimensions
but why roll number happens to be a
numerical value
because the student id will be
considered as
a unique value and w automatically
considers it as a dimension
if if you want that to be in the
measures no problem in that you can just
track it down
into the measures and it will lie in the
measures
from dimensions so that's about the left
tabular column where you can see the
dimensions and
the measures used in your data and
these are the filter options these are
the page options
this is a mark sheet where you can make
some modifications onto your chart by
making different colors sizes of the
charts
adding text to your results and adding
some details adding some tool tip
tooltip is basically something
which explains you about the data which
you're working with
we'll we'll work on that we will see
everything in detail no worries on that
and now coming on to the right side you
can see the
show me tab which will help you with the
various kinds of charts available that
you can work with
so you have text tables you have heat
maps you can have pie charts
you can have single maps and just maps
pie chart and side by side bar
chart stacked bar chart horizontal bars
line graph etc etc you can have scatter
plots
you can have histogram you can have box
and whisker plots
and many more now you will be working
with various types of charts over here
and the best part of tableau is that if
you wanted to use a specific
chart then it will automatically help
you with
the kind of data you need for that for
example if you wanted to go with
text tables you can see that it is
providing you the prescriptions over
here
so it needs one or more dimensions or
one or more measures together on the
rows and columns
in order to you to use this kind of text
table kind of
uh chart to represent your data with and
if you want to go with a pie chart
it says you need to have one or more
dimensions and one
or two measures that is a must if you
have these kind of data's on your rows
and columns
only then you can use a pie chart so
this actually helps you out in real time
and now
let's get started with that data now
let's try to identify
which is the manufacturer with the
highest pricing
now when you double click on the sheet
you can actually edit it
or you can actually right click on that
and just select the rename option
and you can rename it uh now let's
select
the or just write in the highest pricing
yeah there you go highest pricing is the
name of
our sheet right now and now let's grab
the manufacturer
and drop it down under the columns
and now let's select the price from the
measures and
drop it down into the rows yeah there
you go
you can see that we have the data output
on our screen so this particular
bar chart helps us identify that
mercedes
benz has the highest pricing amongst the
other manufacturers
now you can actually make some
modifications onto this chart
like you can increase the size of the
bars it is automatically selected over
here
you can just scroll it to the right and
left by manually and you can
make some changes to the bars and apart
from that
and apart from that you can even choose
an option here
which says the sort ascending by sum of
price with manufacturer
basically it sorts it out so if you
select this particular option you can
sort it
from the least value to the highest
value
in the ascending order and if you choose
this one it will be arranged in the
descending order
and you'll get to see the highest one on
the left and the lowest one on the right
so this is how it works and you can see
that
the first highest pricing manufacturer
is diversity spends
and the least manufacturing pricing is
the infinity and you can see the beamer
over here the bmw
personally i'm a fan of bmw okay
now um and now it's just looking
um you know kind of uh plain without
some
any additional colors or without a
vibrant
way of representing your data i think
you know what i mean
so for that you can just drag the
manufacturer
onto the color option and voila
you can see different colors for
different manufacturers
and this one basically tells you the
highest manufacturer
or this color basically tells you the
highest pricing manufacturer
that is the mercedes-benz and yeah
and another option is
the chart type so basically when you
chose the manufacturer and the
sum of price the tableau automatically
chose the bar chart but you can change
that
you can just select a line over here and
you can see
the complete data has been represented
in the form of a line
and you can even select density
and you can select area
so this is how you can change the way
you can represent your data
so automatic was the best one over here
so basically the
w automatically chose the best way to
represent your data
which happened to be the bar chart you
can even select the shape
though and you can make some changes to
the shapes
so that's how it is
now let's get back to automatic again
and it's it's got the
bar chart again now let's try to create
a new sheet and this time we'll be
working on the horsepower so which
manufacturer
offers the highest horsepower
yeah so we are on the sheet 2 now you
can see that we have named it to
highest horsepower and yeah when you
come back to this when you can see the
name over here
you can even edit your table by just
double clicking on the name
and you can reset some things over here
and that's how it is
and now when we come back to the
horsepower which is the second sheet
i think you remember right we are making
multiple sheets just so that we can work
on our dashboard
so now on the second sheet we'll be
taking up
uh the model name we are going to
identify the
car which is having the highest
horsepower
okay those are a lot of cars
now just select the sort option
and there you go we have the dodge viper
yeah dodge
wiper happens to be a muscle car and
yeah it should be having the highest
horsepower
in the manufacturing model or what do
you say it
the basic model without any
modifications to it extra modifications
so the production model of the viper
will be having a 450
brick horsepower that's really huge
now we can actually make some
modifications
since we have different manufacturers
like
mark and any other manufacturers
you can actually categorize the models
over here you just need to
drag the manufacturer over here and
you can bring the manufacturer to the
first position
and then the model okay another trick i
would like to tell you guys is
if you wanted to switch the manufacturer
with the model
then all you have to do is just drag the
model and
place it on the manufacturer this will
automatically switch them
okay i didn't place it correctly i hope
so when you do it
it will actually switch it yeah that's
how it's done
so we're going to categorize this models
based on the manufacturer now let's
bring back our manufacturer
now let's drag it to the second place
and now we have the manufacturer first
so you can see that the data got
automatically categorized based on the
manufacturer you can see we have acura
which happens to be the american version
of honda
so we have integra rltl what happens to
be
the car or model names so these are the
cars
offered from acura with the horsepower
255 oh
no it's 225 and 210
and 140 so this is actually the tooltip
which is giving you
the data according to that bar chart
and now we have the dodge viper here
with the highest horsepower in the
production model
you know the dodge and the ford are
known for their muscle cars with highest
horsepower
and here we have the merck and
mitsubishi nissan
and some other plymouth porsche
etc etc now we'll go ahead and
create our next worksheet
so let's name it the fuel efficiency
now let's select the manufacturer
and the field efficiency on the rows
now let's select a different type of
chart over here
i think you remember the color option
and if you close the show me option and
then you can see
the manufacturer over here now you can
just
make some changes for it you can
actually select a manufacturer
and you can either keep only or you can
remove it so in in table you have the
control set
option which will undo the changes you
have done
you can actually exclude if you want
someone to be excluded from the list
so i've excluded
buick so this was the one we excluded
so that's how you can do it
so when you press on the tool tip you
can see that we'll be having the
manufacturer
and followed by manufacturer will be
having the fuel efficiency provided by
the manufacturer so you can see that we
have the
good fuel efficiency from chevrolet and
the considerable efficiency from jaguar
so basically jaguars are the luxury cars
which provide you the maximum comfort
and maximum drive
feel so it will actually consume a lot
of fuel
now let's get back and create another
sheet and
let's name it as highest resale
now let's select the highest resale
value
and model
now let's arrange it see according to
that
carrera cabrio has the highest resale
value
that's good
let's drag the color and there you go
let's have the manufacturer here so that
we can have a good
idea of which
manufacturer has the highest resale
value
so mercedes has the highest resale value
and
also we have the model names over here
you can remove a model from marks this
is the reason why we have
multiple cars from single manufacturer
so we have all the cars from a single
manufacturer
if you remove this model from the marks
sheet
you can just see the manufacturer here
now actually we can make some changes to
the sizes we have the size option in our
mark sheet right
so you can just drag and drop the
manufacturer on the size
and then you have various sizes for the
various options and when you come to the
rows you can see that we have the sum of
resale values
basically you can make some changes to
it
uh you can just select measure and
inside measure
you have various options of providing
average
median count minimum maximum so let's go
with
maximum and now let's try to drag the
manufacturer again onto the size and
this time you have
the different sizes so you have porsche
over here
mercedes-benz over here so this is how
the categorization takes place
now let's create a new sheet and
understand the filter option
now just let's name it as filter
and now let's drag the manufacturer
so we have the manufacturer in our
columns and now
uh yeah we discussed that uh the highest
pricing is from mercedes right so
if we wanted to find the next leading
one
uh actually you can see it on the screen
but just imagine that we have a lot of
options
rather than the few options which are
available on the screen then
what if you wanted to find the second
leading
highest pricing car so in that case you
can just
make some filters onto it right you can
add or remove options using filter
so i would like to drag the manufacturer
into filter
and select all from the list
okay and apply
now you can just select the filter
right click it and edit filter and you
can see
all the options over here just select
ok
now let's right click the manufacturer
and select the
show filter option so that you can have
a filter
bar on the right side so now you can
actually remove some options by
selecting them
if you just click on the mercedes fence
you can actually see the mercedes-benz
got removed from the
list so you can see after the most
dispense
the highest pricing is from dodge and
lexus
so this is how you can use filters let's
bring back mercedes-benz again
yeah there you go so so far we have
dealt with the
bar charts and the overlapping bar
charts
or what do you call it this is the stack
pass here i forgot
and uh line graphs now we will deal with
the scatter plots and pie charts now
yeah so for that let's create a new
worksheet
let's name it as scatter plot
there you go okay spelling mistake
so when you had to use the scatter plot
the
special thing about scatter plot is you
need to select both the axis that is
row and column and when you're selecting
the
values for rows and columns you need to
select the values
from this particular segment which
happens to be
the measures so you'll not be selecting
anything from
the dimensions so for now
let's select the engine size for columns
and
horsepowers for rows
so we've selected the engine size for
columns and
horsepower for rows
so once you have selected the data you
can see a dot over here
which happens to be the engine size for
70 and
horse bar 28 000 for 28
this is some random value now
let's take a bit more detail into the
scale plot
now to know the exact details of
all the models and all the engine size
and horsepower
let's drag the model name into
the detail now you have some good
uh you know a more representative or
the more readable form of data
so you can see that we have the highest
horsepower engine
that is torch viper and the engine size
is eight
liters and the horsepower offered as
450.
now if you have dragged the manufacturer
into the details
then you can see that we have the
manufacturer name as well
so the wiper belongs to dodge
and
if you kind of select the manufacturer
into shape
then we can actually have different
shapes for different manufacturers
so you have the shape option over here
so you can see that we have
various shapes for various makers for
example we have the plus symbol for bmw
so if you can just select keep only bmw
then we have
two cars from bmw which happens to be
the model 320i
and the engine size is around 2.8 liters
and the horsepower as 193 brake
horsepower
and another car we have from bmw
is the 323i with the engine size 2.5
and the horsepower 170. now if you want
to bring back
all the cars the simple step is just
press control set
and you have all the cars back in here
and if you want to highlight a specific
car
then select the highlighting option
and then let's select dutch
you can see the dodge cars got
highlighted over here
so just select dodge viper
and then we have dodge durango i don't
know how to spell that if
i'm sorry if it's wrong and then dodge
ram van and
we have the dutch enterprise over here
so if we hover on to the highlighted
parts we have the dodge over there
so that's how you highlight it now we
have worked on
the scatter plot now let's create a new
sheet and let's work on the pie chart
now
i'm just writing pie and it's done
so for a pie chart uh you need to
select an option and hold ctrl
and select another option together and
then
we can do a pie chart so for that
let's follow the steps open show me
select pie chart
okay uh i forgot to say actually we need
to select the dimensions first
so let's select something from
dimensions
okay let's select manufacturer
and hold control and let's select
some value from the measures
so let's select the sales
so now open show me
and there you go you have the tab
so i'm in the pie chart in the tab so we
have the pie chart over here
now i think we can increase the size of
the pie chart
so you can just drag it manually and
you can see that the pie chart size is
getting increased
so here we have the manufacturer
and it has the sales the ford has the
highest
sales and uh followed by
ford we have dodge and then we have
honda and chevrolet toyota
so so far we have understood the types
of charts you can make
the types of options that are color size
label detail
tooltip etc etc and filters
and the show me tab etc etc now we will
move ahead and try to understand
hierarchy in w
so let's kind of make a new sheet
let's rename it as hierarchy
now we know that the model and
manufacturer
can be considered as an hierarchy
because a model comes under manufacturer
so we can use these two from dimensions
and use them as hierarchies
now let's try to drag model onto
manufacturer
and this should automatically show me a
dialog box on my screen
now let's rename it as manufacturer
model hierarchy
or just let it be as h so that it's
a bit more readable now you can see that
we have the manufacturer model h
hierarchy and inside that we have the
manufacturer and
model now we can like
drag the manufacturer model hierarchy
onto columns
and we can drag the car sales
into rows and we have the hierarchy
values over here
let's rearrange them and now if you
press
the plus option it's really mind you
don't know how to expand the screen
let's try control plus r shift plus
it's not working so i think you can see
the
my new plus option over here
now let's try to press that plus option
and there you go you have these sales
according to the
manufacturer and the models and that too
in hierarchy let's remove the car sales
and
try to put in the horsepower over there
yeah you can see the horsepower of each
and every car
which is categorized according to the uh
manufacturer so infor we have various
types of cars available
and similarly in toyota mercedes-benz
chevrolet mitsubishi
etc etc so that's how
the irrq works now i hope we had a sound
understanding of
how to create various types of charts
and
we have the filter option scatter plot
pie chart hierarchy everything discussed
so far i think you have a brief idea how
to work with
w now let's go through an example of
dashboards now let's rename this
dashboard as
car dashboard
now dashboard is no rocket science the
only thing you do is just
select the charts you've worked on and
drag them onto your
dashboard that's all now let's select
the scatter plot
and drag it onto the chart
and now let's try to
drag the horse bar
and now the fuel efficiency
so you can see the horsepower and
fuel efficiency and highest number of
sales
and the horsepower compared to engine
size
all together on one dashboard
so you can see the dashboard name over
here which is a car dashboard
now you can have some options over here
like you can download the dashboard
image
and much more
you can even make multiple dashboards
just like we made
the worksheets and then you can
interconnect the dashboards and you can
work
multiple operations on multiple
dashboards i hope you had a good
understanding of
tableau in taboo tutorial for beginners
and now let's get back to the
presentation
so today we'll be dealing with the
tableau project so the first data set
that we will be using for the tableau
project is based on covet 19 data
followed by that we'll have another
project based on the airline data
and finally the third project will be
based on space
missions data now let's begin with our
first
project so in this first project we'll
be dealing with the covert 19 data set
and using that data set will be getting
some insights
so what are those insights those are
what are the total number of
confirmed cases in different nations
what are the total number of recovered
cases in different nations so we'll be
using the
map chart for these and we'll be finding
out the insights about
how are the cases going on in the
current situation or in the current
date or year followed by that we'll also
look into the insights of the confirmed
and recovered cases in india as well
followed by that we'll enter into the
next query where we'll find out the
trend line of code 19 in the
international level like how it started
how is it going on
and moving forward will create a group
of indian states and we'll find out the
covert heads there
and then we will discuss about the death
rates so highest death rates at
international level and the
least death rates in the international
level then we'll enter into the next
segment where we'll find out the
variation in covert 19 cases around the
world
and then finally we'll discuss the
future of covert 19 in the international
level
basically we'll create a trend line
which will give us the forecast levels
of the covert 19 like is it going to
increase or is it going to decrease
or what's going to happen in the near
future so i hope i made myself clear
with the queries or the insights that
we're going to take from the covert 19
data set
using table u so without further ado
let's get started with the w so we are
on tableau right now so we'll be using
an excel data file
so we'll be using the covert 19 data
file so this particular data set is
available on kaggle
and if you don't find it there don't
worry we'll be attaching that particular
data set in the description box below
you can use that as well
now let's just select open to get
connected with that particular data
so you can see that we just got
connected with that data
and
there will be some minute errors in the
data or
there will be some problem with the data
which the
table you might identify and
when it identifies something messy with
the data it will show you an option
maybe you might want to use the data
interpreter so
i prefer using that so whenever i see
that particular
option on the left hand side i better
use it
for the safer side for being for being
on safer side with the data
and let's also select these not a
problem
yeah so the data got clean now you can
see that over here so
to do that you can also check the review
results so when you click that review
results option then you'll get into this
particular excel document
which will help you with the changes
made to that data set so you can see
that
the orange color one sees the data is
interpreted as column headers
or field name and the green box suggests
you that data is interpreted as
values in your data source and now you
can see that
there you go
so now we'll get back to w now you can
see that
the data has been interpreted
successfully by the w and everything is
uh as expected by the table every every
data element in the
data set is as expected by the table and
it's really fine now
now we'll check the columns what we have
in our data set right over here
so we have the serial numbers
observation dates province
state and the country or region last
update and confirmed
death recovered so basically these three
columns will be telling us the confirmed
cases in that particular region country
or state
and the debts happen in that region
country of state and recovered rate
and the last update when was the last
test done
the latest tested done and in which
region and what's the observation date
what's the observation results on that
particular date and the serial numbers
etc etc
so we have the clear understanding of
our data set now let's get started with
the first sheet what we have over here
so according to our first query we had
to find out the total number of
confirmed cases in different nations
so for that we might want to select the
country or region
and then the confirmed from
measures so for that we'll be selecting
the map chart for this
so that we have the data shown in a more
appealing format
so now we have the blue color of
map on a screen right now where the
darkest color shows the maximum number
of
cases confirmed and the lighter ones
represent the lower number of cases
confirmed
now let's let's make this look a little
more interesting
so for that we can select the edit color
options and
inside that let's select the red
to green diverging
yeah this is it red to green white
divergent
and uh uh as you can see the colors are
a little opposite right now
so we want the greener one in the lower
side and the red colored one on the
higher side
this should be good so let's select okay
and apply and okay
so you can see that the red color now
represents the highest number of cases
and a lighter red one here you can see
the
a little touch of red which shows that
the india's got some
good amount of cases as well and in the
brazil and
et cetera et cetera so even russia has a
little light
green so this shows it also has some
good amount of cases not not completely
green though
yeah so this is how it looks now let's
rename the sheet as
confirmed cases
at the international level
now according to our second query
we are supposed to find the total number
of recovered cases in different nations
so now let's create a new sheet for that
now for that we'll be selecting the
country or region and then we'll be
selecting the
recovered and uh hover over to the show
me icon
and let's select the mac for that
now you can see that we have a lot of
recovery happening in
india so according to the stats we get
to hear that
the virus which we have in india is a
little
you know kind of harmful than
comparatively
what we had in china and other states of
the world
or the other nations of the world so
yeah we have a good recovery rate in
india
now let's rename the sheet as recovery
recovered cases
international level
yeah so i'm naming these sheets
separately because we'll be using these
sheets to create a dashboard at the end
now let's get into the third query what
we have right now is
find the total number of confirmed cases
in india and
what are the total number of recovered
cases in india
so for that let's create a new sheet
and let's select country or region
and confirmed now we'll be selecting the
text table and we have the
complete data set right now we have all
the nations over here so
what we are looking for is just india
so for that now we'll drag the country
or region into filters
and inside this you can see we have an
option of selecting india
now let's search for india
g h i so we have india over here let's
select apply
and okay so we have the total number of
cases in
india now we can drag
the state of province into a rows
add all members so in india we have all
the states
and so all the states have their own
confirmed cases
so this is the total confirm state or
confirm count in
india let's rename this sheet
confirmed
cases
in india
similarly let's find the recovery cases
in
india let's create a new sheet for that
rename it as recovery
cases in india
so now let's select the country region
recovery and then
let's close the show me icon and
now let's drag the control region to
filters then
none select india
apply okay and
let's drag the state of province here at
all numbers yeah so you have the
text chart here which represents the
total number of recovered cases in india
according to the state wise
now yeah this looks okay but we can
make it look a little more appealing so
that
it's it's more you know visible and
understandable readable so we can make
that happen so let's make a duplicate of
this
and recovery cases as well
now i would like to change the confirm
cases in india into a pie chart
which looks a little bit more readable
and understandable let's select the
entire view so that we have
a bigger pie chart and a little bit
understandable
or readable let's increase the size a
little bit and let's select the
label and select the show mark label so
that we have all the
numbers over here we can even select the
uh province of state and drag it into
detail so we have the state's name as
well
or should we tag it into label
yeah now the recovered into label again
yeah there you go we have this state and
we have the confirm number over here
so this is how we can make the data look
a bit more appealing and
understandable so we can see that
maharashtra has
a larger number of confirmed cases it's
the biggest state of india
so maybe yeah that's true and now we'll
get back to the duplicate sheet of
recovery cases in india and now
let's make it look a bit more appealing
by changing the way the data looks
so for this we can select the packed
bubble option now we can see the
bubbles which show the uh recovery
states happening in the indian states or
the recovery cases
so you can see that everything is
looking in
blue color a bit difficult to understand
so
for that let's drag the province or
state into
color so that we can have different
colors for different states
yeah now this is good we have the
country name
and state name this is fine now
we can make it a bit more readable by
dragging the recovered icon into
or the recovered pill into the label
so we have the count of recoveries
happening in that particular state
and that particular country now it's a
bit more readable
now we have maharashtra at the leading
place
we have a good recovery in maharashtra
yeah that's fine
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and see our
next query so can we forecast the trend
line of covert 19 here
so how it started how is it going on so
we can do that let's get back to w again
so let's create a new sheet we have the
new sheet over here let's rename that as
trend line
yeah the sheet got renamed now let's
select the
observation date from the
dimensions since you're making a
trendline so let's keep it
observation date or you can even select
the last update
let's go with the last update now let's
select the confirmed
fill from measures
let's select a line chart
or we can do that from here as well
okay so we're not getting the line chart
so there might be some problem
with the date format over here
so we have to change the data type of
so i think this might be something with
the
date yeah let's select the date pill
and change the data type to
date or date and time from string so you
can see we had a string first
so now let's change to date and time
now we'll be getting a proper trend line
so now we have
it according to the year so we can make
it according to
quarter and uh even even
even in the form of months and so if you
see this a little bit
readable you can keep it that way or you
can even change to days
so yeah
i think there is some problem with
dating time value
so let's keep it in the form of months
it's it's more readable in one screen so
yeah it's good let's remove this
so we have the month update
now let's go to analytics to create a
trend line and you can select the trend
line and drag it over here
and select the linear option so you can
see here
we have the trend line over here which
reach the r squared and p values and
confirm
and we have a formula for that so
basically tabulate creates a formula to
create a trendline
so which is 5.280
exponent to the power of 8 into
month of last update so very pretty
pretty
complex formula yet understandable
so this is how you create a trend line
so according to the trends we have
january february
the quartus q1 q2 q3 q4 and this is the
first month of january so
here it is so in in january we find
one okay
this is in billions maybe yeah maybe
even trillions
who knows but but based on the
data we have in the last year we have
a decrement of the confirmed cases in
january so it's basically
indicating that corona yes basically are
slowly
decreasing that's a good sign
now now let's try to find out the trend
line for
india let's duplicate this
so for that let's drag the country into
filters
we have the filter option and
let's select all no no not
all we might want to select uh the
indian icon
yeah let's select apply
okay so now we have the trend line for
india let's kind of rename it
yeah even even you can see a gradual
drop
of corona in india as well
so the number has decreased in india as
well
in the earlier year we had a lot of
cases
uh above 30 crores now we have
nearly 20 crores that's a good sign in
india as well
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and try to select the next query
so according to the next query uh can we
group indian states and
find covert 19 hits yeah we can do that
now let's get back to tableau for that
let's create a new sheet and
let's rename it as grouped so the
sheet got renamed now we're going to
select the country or region
or province now for that
uh you can see the create option over
here now inside that let's select the
group
now we have to create a group of
indian nations so select
andaman and ecobar hold control select
andhra pradesh
now let's select a couple of states we
know
which are in india arunachal pradesh
assam
don't forget to hold the ctrl key for
this or else the options
might vanish
we have bihar
we have chandigarh
we have chapter
we have dadar and nagar
yeah we are going to just select a
couple of uh
states uh just to show how um
group can be done so fetching all the
states in this particular
column would be a little difficult or we
might even miss a few
we have got
we have haryana
we have islamabad
we have karnataka
we have kerala
the dark dream
we have madhya pradesh maharashtra
nagaland
we have punjab
we have rajasthan
we have tamil nadu with telangana
we have the pradesh
we have west bengal
and
let's rename the group as
indian states group
let's select apply and okay
so uh after selecting the apply option
and
clicking ok so we can have a new pill in
the dimensions section
that happens to be indian states group
so what we're going to do is
drag that bill into detail option so
that we can have the results on our
screen
so there you go the states what we
selected are
right over here all the jammu kashmir
and
punjab maharashtra gujarat et cetera et
cetera
and our lakshadweep and the andaman and
nicobar islands
right so we have all the states of india
right on our screen
okay um let's expand it a little bit
scrolling on tableau is a little bit
difficult
i don't know how to select the default
option
for the screen
yes um we can see these states
i don't know where this crawler is at
yeah we can always undo what we did in w
so that's the best part
now let's drag the state spell again so
that we can have a perfect map
in the screen right now yeah
i would like to not to mess with it
again it's
it's pretty good right now let's keep it
as it is now let's quickly get back to
our presentation
and check out our next query so find the
highest
death rates at international level so we
we are basically going to find which
nation or the country has the highest
death rates and which is the country
with the least amount of death rates so
which is the safest country
now let's get back to tabalee now we're
not going to mess with this particular
sheet
let's create a new sheet let's rename
the sheet as
highest death rates
international i n t l
let's enter so the
sheet got renamed successfully let's
drag in country
and let's drag and confirm cases
so we have a map over here so w
basically kind of selected the
map as default we can drag the depths
and now we can actually change this to
a text chart
now let's drag the measure names into
rows so we have a little bit more
you know sorted kind of data so you can
see we have the country cases over here
and
that trades here now if we kind of sort
it
in the descending order
yeah so the uh order is being changed
now
so we have uh so we have our
charts processed by tableau for a better
visual
so our chart got rearranged or ordered
in the descending order
so with that we have the highest you
know
uh deaths and confirmed cases in us so
we can even do that using a
parameter where you can create the
top 10 or top five nations with highest
confidence
values so for that you can
drag both
oh no you need to create a parameter
i think it's not required over here
let's continue with
the next sheet or you can just simply
duplicate this
since the data set is a little huge it
takes a little bit of time
now let's rename this
yeah now let's rename this sheet
it's still taking a little bit of time
yeah now i think we can rename it least
death rates so now for that we're gonna
rearrange it in the descending order
i'm an ascending order
so yeah after sorting and changing some
layouts we have the
least number of uh cases or death rates
in
the country called makkah where we have
least number of deaths and least number
of confirmed cases
so with that let's move into the
presentation mode again
and in the presentation mode we have our
next
query that says can we find the
variation in code 19 cases around the
world
so for that let's create a new sheet
again if getting your learning started
is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description
to know more so after changing some
arrangements or by making an ascending
arrangement and
changing the layout or the orientation
and everything we have our final result
which states that we have the least
number of debts and confirmations
of covert 19 in the country of
afghanistan
so yeah so we have the predictable
sorted arranged data over here on the
screen
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and in the presentation mode the
next query that we have to deal with is
can we find the variation in cobin 19
cases around the world
yeah we can do that so let's get back to
w and
create a new sheet let's rename the
sheet as
a variation
of c one nine
yeah it's done so to find out the
variation of covert 19
we might want to use the boxes and
viscous chart
let's select the country region pill
from dimensions and
confirm from measures let's arrow to the
show me tab and select the box and
whisker plot
yeah so you can see that we just have
one box of whisker over here
when you see something like this
happening on your sheet then directly
head over to analytics and
uncheck the aggregate measures so we
have
this kind of visualization maybe we
forgot something
so we've got the country or region to be
placed in columns
so when you place it in the columns
section then you find out all the
countries and the variation of
kubernetes in their
region now let's um sort it in the
descending order so that we can find out
the maximum variation which is happening
in france
so of course there are less number of
confirmed cases
but there is a lot of variation which
states that
they have something wrong with the
climatic conditions or the weather
conditions there
yeah we have a larger confirmations
in our larger cases in u.s but there is
some uh some data which
shows that france is leading in some
variation yeah so um since we're
calculating the variation of the
confirmation of covert 19 presents
we have france in the first place where
it shows that there is a lot of
variation in the
confirmed cases in france rather than
u.s
yeah that's how we can find the
variation of
presence of covert 19 in a particular
country
so with that let's move into the next
query so
the next query is can we forecast the
sheet of future
and reference of code 19 presence
yes we can do that let's get back to w
for that let's create a new sheet and
rename it as forecast
of co with 19
presents
so the sheet got renamed successfully
now
we'll select the observation date from
the dimensions
and confirm fill from measures
so we'll use them drag it to columns and
the confirm from yeah
now we're going to change this okay
there is something wrong with the
observation date
for that let's select the observation
fill and change the data type to
date yeah so far so good
now let's select this to
day oh we can
change that to here
now let's select four cat option yeah
so this is how it's going to be
so in the year of 2020 we had the
confirmed cases around this number which
is 767053464
so which is nearly 76
370 lakh and
in the 2021 the number got a little
decreased
which is 17 130 lakh
cases and uh in the end of 2022 which is
the forecast we can see there is a
little
more drop so it's a good sign that the
covert nineteen is getting decreased so
this is the forecast of the covet 19
presence in india
so we can change the path
to a stepped one the line is okay the
line is pretty good
no worries on that so basically we
finished the queries on our presentation
mode
so yeah if we get back to the
presentation mode so all the queries on
the covet 19 data are finished
now let's create a dashboard
yeah we have the dashboard right now so
we can change the layout of dashboard
let me
increase the width to 1320 and
decrease the height to 70 or 760.
so we have the entire screen right now
now
let's drag in the confirm cases of
international level
and the recovery cases of the
international level
yeah now we have it okay or
let's keep it in the top and that in the
bottom
the trend line of code in the
international level
and the highest death rates
in the international level
it takes a little time
it's still taking a little bit more time
i don't know what's wrong
okay it should be done in some time
let's wait
it's basically taking a lot of time
because we have a lot of data in that
particular sheet
let's kind of change that a little
now let's change the sheet to
or we can just remove this from the
dashboard and
select the least depth rate or the top
10
least death rates so we have sheet right
over here we have the top 10 ones only
here yeah this is good so this is how we
can have the dashboard
and now let's create another dashboard
for indian results
so again let's uh change the
dimensions of the screen
yeah it's pretty good now let's take the
confirm cases in india
and drop it over here and recovery cases
in india and drop it over there
and trend lines in india over here
and
indian states
in the forecast
somewhere over here
and if we get back to the dashboard one
we can even
add the forecast data or the variation
data
somewhere over here
and we can always change the height
so that it's a bit more visible
so we can rename the dashboard
c 1 9
international dashboard
and this one has
c one nine
indian dashboard
yeah so with that we have finished the
first project based on the
covert 19 data set now we'll continue
with the next
data set that is the airline data set
so now we are in the second project and
the second project is about the airline
data set
and in this particular data set we're
going to take the insights which are as
follows
what are the total number of flights
which are taking off
in a day from the san francisco airport
and
followed by that we have the next query
which reads out find the
busiest day of san francisco airport
we'll be finding out the top five
busiest air days in the san francisco
airport and followed by that will also
find what are the total number of
flights
per day in a month then we'll find out
what are the top 10 busiest flight
routes then we'll find out
what are the top 10 longest flight
routes from
san francisco airport then we have to
represent the flights flying outside the
san francisco
towards different parts of the world
using a map chart
so these are the queries that we'll be
executing in our second project without
further ado let's get back to the w
so now we are back on the w dashboard so
let's select our data set for today
so our data set is somewhere
here
yeah this is the air travel data set we
were looking for
now we got our air travel data set
loaded onto w
so remember i said about the interpreter
i'll select that and show earlier
okay let the query execute
yeah so the interpreter query got
executed now the
data has been cleaned we can review the
results by clicking on review results
option over here
we have another query executed now
basically this query will take us to the
microsoft excel sheet
where our claimed data is readily
available for us
there you go we can see that the red
colored data is the
data that is interpreted as column
headers or field names
the green color one is the data
interpreted as the values in your data
source
so it looks something like this so we
have our data
fine over here just looking fine now
when you come into the
root column you have san francisco to
the other parts of the world for example
we have los angeles here
etc etc but we don't have a separate
field
for origin and a destination so what
we'll be doing
is we'll be splitting this particular
column uh
right away here so let's navigate to the
last column which will show us the root
so you can right click this
and select the option of slit which will
basically split it into
two halves which will give us the from
destination or the origin of the
airplane and to or the destination of
the plane
so from to or the origin destination
fields we have right now over here you
can see that
so far so good so let's quickly begin
with our
worksheet
now we are on the worksheet right now so
what was our first query so our first
query was to find the total number of
flights
in a day so for that
we have a simple step so basically we'll
have
a particular number of rows right for
the data set what we've selected we will
have some thousands of data sets
so each and every row is actually a
flight
so what we will do is just create a
calculated field and
just name it as number of
rows okay since we are trying to
calculate the total number of flights
let's you know kind of uh not
name it as rows instead we'll name it as
flights
and inside the health related field just
write one
and it should be done so you can see the
number of slides
just over here just hover down the text
and we'll have the number over here so
this is the total number of flights
per day which takes off from the san
francisco airport
let's kind of increase the text size so
that it's a bit more
visible
yeah that should be it uh let's rename
the sheet
from here i would i i would do the
renaming
from here because it's a little simple
total number of flights
yeah that should be it now let's get on
to the presentation mode again
now let's uh you know execute the second
query
find the busiest day at san francisco
airport
so to execute the second query uh let's
just simply duplicate the sheet
and rename the sheet as um
busiest okay we can actually schedules
of flights
or not schedules of flights
number of lights
or we can rename this as
flights taking off
so when we get the count of flights
taking off
then we can actually find the date which
was really busy like the date with the
maximum amount of
uh you know flights taking off that
would be the
busiest day so the data type is date by
default that's great
now let's drag it to columns
now the sum of numbers at
this place
analysis let's uncheck this to get a map
let's make it by month
or
okay we don't need this
we don't need this
we all need this as well
now we have a chart over here let's
change it
to scatter plot maybe
yeah so we have the chart no worries on
this caterpillar thing it's it's
really a scatter plot and don't know
what is on that so right now we need to
find out the busiest days
so for that we might want to drag the
date into
filter and let's select the individual
dates select
next and inside the top we have the oh
yeah
we need to select by field and now we
have the top
10 number of lights on yeah we need we
need the top 10
flies so let's select apply
we needed top one but uh why not top
then
you will select top 10 for that now we
have the scatter plot on my sheet right
now
so let's kind of uh arrange it in the
descending order this shows the
highest number of flights or okay
we need to change this
value to sum
yeah there is some
so uh yeah i got to know where we made a
mystic
so inside analysis we were supposed to
aggregate the measures so that we can
get the sum
of number of lights now we have the
total number of flights
now let's quickly uh arrange this
now we have the
three thousand one hundred sixty six
three thousand
two hundred thousand two ninety five
yeah so three thousand 3295 happens to
be our
you know busiest day in the year 2020
that is the sixth march
which had the maximum number of flights
taking off
so we can actually make a set of these
the set of these which happens to be in
the march so
much happens to be the busiest month for
san francisco airport
so with that we have finished the second
query now let's create a new sheet for
our third query let's get back to the
presentation
and the third query it reads that what
are the total number of flights
per day in a month so for that let's get
back to w
let's try to rename it total
flights in a month
done so for that let's select
date and drag it to columns and
let's make it to month
let's remove this let's remove this
let's remove this as well now let's
check it to
day and now number of flights
so automatically we have a line chart
and we have the flights taking off from
march 1st to march
31st which happens to be the busiest
month for san francisco airport now
let's just
take the show mark label so that we have
the number of flights taking off every
day
so as we got the result in the previous
sheet 290 or
300 3295 flights
on the date of sixth march or is the
third march maybe yeah
that happened sixth march that happened
to be the busiest day of uh san
francisco airport
let's get back to the presentation and
check the
fourth query so the fourth query reads
what are the top 10 busiest
flight routes for that let's get back to
tableau again
let's rename the newly created sheet
busiest
routes
now the uh sheet is being replaced or
renamed
now to find out the top busiest routes
we need a calculated field to remove the
effects of
san francisco airport first so clinton
create a calculated field and we can
name it as
busiest route pc
and now inside the calculated field we
need an if condition
then if
route 1 split 1 is
equals to sfo
then
route 2 split two
else route one
and
yeah the calculation is valid let's
apply and
okay
now we have the newly created calculated
we field
somewhere here now we'll drag that into
rows
and now we'll drag the number of flights
to
columns
so there we go we have the bar chart
over here
let's um you know rearrange it in
descending order so that we get the
you know descending order now we needed
the
top 10 or top busiest routes with that
let's drag
busy into filters select top
and by field we have top 10 let's just
select
apply and ok and we have the top
busiest routes from san francisco
airport or sfo
now let's get back to the presentation
mode and in the presentation mode the
next query is which are the top
longest flight rules from sfo
so to find out the longest routes we'll
create a new sheet and rename it as
our busiest no not busiest
longest longest routes
yeah the sheet is renamed and you can
see that we have geometry coordinates 0
0
0 1 1 0 and 1 1. so these
z okay not 0 1 1 and 1
0 coordinates basically provide the
origin
information and 0 0 and 0 1 provide the
destination information
so we'll be creating a calculated field
for that
now let's create a calculated field
so let's rename the calculated field as
origin
and inside the origin we'll make use of
make point and inside make point we'll
write
geometry
coordinates one one and geometry
coordinates
we'll need the geometric coordinates one
one and geometric coordinates
one zero separated by comma
and done so we have the origin now let's
create another for destination
we are creating a calculated field
destination
and inside destination we are going to
use the same
make point and geo
metric coordinates 0 0
comma geometric coordinates 0 1
and select apply ok
now the origin and destination are
created now we need to create another
calculated field for
distance so we'll write it as distance
and inside that we'll use the distance
function
and we'll write origin
comma destination
and will represent the distance who
using kilometers
and select apply okay
now we have the newly created distance
measure in the
measure section now we'll drag the busy
into
columns and uh distance into
rows okay uh
we made something oh there's no problem
we can actually change the orientation
and now let's rearrange it in the form
of
descending order now we have the um
distance sorted in the descending order
but there is a small change
we have to change the sum to
average so once you change that you
want to arrange it again now we have the
vlr bangalore
as the farthest airport from sfo
yeah now we might want to drag the
crazy into fill this again now we have
the top
ten apply okay so we have the
top ten longest routes from sfo
so with that we have uh finished our
fifth query let's get back to
presentation mode and
the sixth query represent the flights
flying outside sfo towards different
parts of the world yeah that can be done
let's get back to w again
now for the sixth query let's create a
new sheet let's name it as
map flights
from sfo okay
so for that let's select the latitude
and longitude and select a map
so we have the map right here
now let's change that to map
yeah it's in the map section by default
let's create
a calculated field called
lines so we're basically using lines to
represent
the flights taking off from sfo so i'll
name it as line
or we can name it as flights line
okay and inside the calculated field
let's type in
make line and so inside the field let's
make use of
make line function and inside that let's
write an
origin and separated by comma
destination and the calculation is valid
apply ok
now we have the newly created flight
line over here
now we'll drag that flat line to detail
now once we drag that flight line
to the detail we have the lines our
flights taking off from sfo to different
parts of the world
now we can make it look a bit more
appealing or more informative by
dragging
the roads or yeah
into detail so we have the
details of roots and
we can even drag the distance into
detail so
when we hover over to the line we'll
have the root and the distance as well
yeah so that's how it is done now we're
basically done with all the queries now
let's create a
dashboard so now let's um
you know kind of arrange the dashboard
size convenient to our monitor
so i'll increase it to 1320 width and
decrease the height to 760. so that's
the proper size what i
was looking for now we'll drag the
details into the sheet
longest truths
we have the flights taking off busiest
routes longest routes
and total flights
into here
now it looks more readable fine so we
have the busiest routes we have the
longest routes
we have the flights taking off and the
month of march
the busiest month was the march and the
busiest day was 6th of march
i don't know what was so special on that
day if you know it
please let me know in the comment
section below and yeah
so totally we created a dashboard now
let's
rename the dashboard as
sfo flight data dashboard
and we are done so we are done with the
second project
now let's get back to our presentation
and let's check the last project that
happens to be the space missions data
set
so now we are in the third project which
is based
on space missions data set so using this
particular data set we're going to get
some insights which are based on the
queries on my screen right now so we're
going to find out what are the average
temperature details of the launch sites
what are the average wind speed details
of the launch sites what are the average
humidity details of the launch sites
so we need all these to uh you know
before launching a satellite or a rocket
into space
everything needs to be in ideal
condition so
followed by that we have what are the
different varieties of laundry vehicles
used by different companies so there are
a lot many companies
you are from government sector where
you're from private sector for example
uh usa military satellites belong to
garment
and private satellites like um spacex
yeah and few others next we have what is
the mission status of the company so
we have a list of satellites launched
already right so we need the mission
status of that particular
satellite is it a successful launch or
was there
some failure record or something like
that next at the last query we have the
track records of
launch sites so what are the track
records so what are the successful
launches what are the failure launches
what are the satellites launched by
different companies etc etc we'll have a
complete track record of that
of all the launch sites which are
available in our data set
now without further ado let's get back
to taboo and start
the project so we are on tableau now
we're going to extract the data set
so the data set we need is the space
missions data set you can
get this in the kaggle or you can even
have the access to this data set from
the description box below select
open to open the data so yeah the data
got successfully loaded
again use the interpreter and it's a
good habit of using the interpreters to
clean your data and make everything
understandable or
look understandable show all the asses
everything is fine
so we're good to go with the data set
what we have in our
tableau right now now with that let's
get back to the first sheet
now let's check the first query that we
have in our presentation what are the
average
temperature details of launch sites so
for that
let's create a new sheet yeah it's
created rename it as
avg temperatures
or launch site
temperatures
so now we need the launch site and
select the temperature and hold over to
the show me tab
and let's let the bubbles chart
now you can see the temperature is in
the sum but we don't need the sum here
we need to change that to average
now we have the average temperatures of
the launch sites now
let's kind of select label show marks
here
so we can do one more thing we can
drag the temperature onto the
label now we have the temperature here
now
let's again change the measure to
average now we have the average
temperatures of the launch sites and
fahrenheits
yeah that's pretty well now
let's get back to the presentation and
the next query is what are the average
wind speed details of the launch sites
let's get back to w again
let's create a new sheet launch
site
wind speeds
now let's drag the launch site into
columns
and wind speed from measures into rows
and you can see automatically we have a
bar
chart but to make it a little bit more
readable let's select the
boxes and viscous chart yeah you know
what to do now
go to analysis uncheck the aggregate
measures options
and let's drag the launch site again
onto columns
now we have the different box and
whiskers for different sites
so let's kind of arrange it
yeah so the wind speeds at uh kennedy
space center
are here 20 miles and 23 at
vandenberg and marshall at nine
yeah so this is the wind speeds at
different launch sites
now let's get back to the presentation
mode
and now we have to find the humidity
details of launch sites
so let's get back to tablet and we are
back on tableau let's
rename it humi dt
launch site
now let's select the repeat now let's
select the
launch site and humidity
then a pie chart
the pie chart is really small so we can
select the entire view
now we have the sum of humidity but we
need the average humidity
and now let's drag humidity onto label
and launch site to label now we have the
detailed humidity
now we need to select the measure to
average again and here
to average again yeah so we have the
humidity percentage of
launch sites on the pie chart over here
so with that we are done now let's get
back to presentation again
now our fourth query which states that
what are the different varieties of
launch vehicles used by different
companies for that let's get back to
tableau
now let's create a new sheet
launch vehicle
details
yeah now this query is pretty
straightforward select company and
vehicle type and we should be done
so there we go we have the company name
and vehicles used for the launching of
satellites process
now let's get back to the presentation
mode let's select the
next query what is the mission status of
companies
now let's get back to tableau let's
create
a new sheet and rename it as mission
status
now we are back on tableau now let's
select the
company drag that to columns
and mission status to columns and
well select one
[Music]
parameter from measures so that we can
get a
good bar chart side-by-side bar
chart and now we can
drag the company to color so that we can
have different colors for different
companies
so we have the mission details so
spacex found a maximum success in the
recent days and
little failures and yeah boeing fun
good success as well and some failures
so these are the mission status of
different companies
and different satellites as well so we
have even u.s air force here faced
some satellites here some failures and
some satellites it's okay
so now let's get back to presentation
mode
now the sixth query is track records of
lunch
sites we had
the payload as sum so we change it to
count
distinct count so now we have a better
observation of failures and successes
over here
so as we discussed in the sixth query
now we need to find the track records of
launch sites now let's create a new
sheet
rename it as track records
and now let's drag the company to
columns and
mission status to columns again and now
let's
drag the
launch site yeah i think we might want
to drag the mission status to
rows yeah
let's create click on text
now let's drag the space mission scan to
color
and space mission counter labels
let's use this one yeah now we have the
um
state stats or the track records of
different
space centers or launch sites and we
have the failures and success
rates over here yeah so basically we
have done the last
sheet or last query executed now let's
create a new dashboard
as we always do change the resolution
according to
the monitor we have so i'm gonna use
1030p
and height as 760. now let's drag the
sheets
so we have the launch temperatures
launch wind speeds and launch site
humidity
at one place now the
launch vehicles used mission status
and the track records
so we'll kind of drag it here
and this one over here this
little bit over here and this one over
here
so now we can actually you know
select the track records of cape
carnival
we have the site temperature we have the
site humidity we have the site
wind speed and the track records of that
particular site and launch vehicles
launched
mission status everything on one single
dashboard
so that's how you make use of dashboards
in real time with that we have reached
the end of this w for data science
tutorial i hope it was interesting and
informative
if you have any queries then please feel
free to leave them down in the comment
section below
our team of experts will be happy to
hear it from you and resolve all your
queries
until next time thank you stay safe and
keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here
you